So here's our camera section for the UMG fundamentals.
So let's see what we're trying to set up here.
So we can have a series of cameras, as mentioned at the outset,
that we'll have around the car, and then we'll just cycle through them.
So the amount of cameras doesn't matter,
but just place a few cameras around your scene looking at the car.
So let's jump into Unreal and add those now.
So I'll just go to my place actors, and we'll go to cameras,
and we'll add a cine camera actor.
So I'm just going to move these around the scene and kind of look at the car.
I'm going to change the world to local, so I can kind of rotate in.
And you may want to change some lens settings here.
You know, if you want some wider shots of the car,
obviously the focal length may change in that respect.
So just add a few cameras here.
I'm just going to change the world to grid again.
You just want some kind of nice wide shot.
So we don't, I'm not again going to be too focused on what these cameras are looking at,
some kind of cool angles.
Maybe, maybe I can't resist.
Let's just get a nice low shot from the back there.
Yeah, cool.
Okay, enough with the cameras.
We've got four cameras in the scene.
Again, the number doesn't matter here.
We essentially just want to create some kind of functionality to cycle through them.
So we want to go back into our UMG.
Before that, I'm just going to save, save all before we continue.
And then I'm going to jump into the UMG.
So essentially the setup will be this in the UMG graph editor.
So we're going to pre construct again, like we had last time,
we're going to add a few materials here.
We'll get the cameras, promote them to a variable.
We've got an on clicked event.
So we'll get the next camera and the pre construct event.
We'll gather all the cameras, store them in a button press and do all the heavy lifting.
So just to note that the order of the cameras is based on the order that I just place them in
and what you place them in the scene.
So the system doesn't number and label them.
We could do that later on.
But for the purposes of this scene, let's just go ahead and add the functionality that we need.
So we'll jump back into the editor here and we'll jump into the light cam UMG.
We'll go back into our event graph.
And we've also, we've got this display vehicle here.
So on the pre construct, what we want to do this time is get all actors of class.
So the mistake that I made previously, this is now why we want all actors of class
because it'll return an array and that'll give us a list of cameras.
So we want Cine camera actor here.
So I added Cine camera actors.
If you just added a normal camera actor, you would just add camera actor.
But from this map, I added a Cine camera actor.
So that's what I'm looking for in this UMG.
So again, compile and save, just get into the habit of that.
And I'm going to drag off the array here, set.
I'm going to call this list of cameras.
And you'll see that it has got Cine camera actor here as a variable type, which is what we want to see.
Again, if it's turned to actor for some reason, it might just be because I hadn't assigned the actor class when I promoted the variable before.
So you just want to make sure that that's all hooked in correctly.
And now we want to add an event to the on clicked to the camera button.
So let's go to the designer.
Let's go to the camera button here.
I'm going to scroll down.
And if I have the camera button selected, on clicked is going to be there.
So I'm going to add on clicked here.
And so we want first an integer.
So I'm going to add a variable here and I'm going to call that integer current camera.
Again, just capitalizing my letters.
I'm going to go to the Boolean.
Add an integer.
And so that's an integer.
So I'm going to get the integer and going to get it.
And then I want to also set this integer as well.
So holding down alt, I'm going to set it.
I'm going to drag the construct, the click into the set cameras.
Now we essentially want to get the current camera, add one to it.
So it goes to the next camera from the list of cameras and then assign the current camera.
So we want to increment this.
So there is an increment integer, but we just want the add for now.
So we're just going to add one to the integer like that.
And then I'm going to get the list of cameras.
So I'm going to hold down control, list of cameras.
I'm going to get the length of this because the length gets the number of cameras in the array.
So if I've got four in my scene, it'll get an array of four.
It doesn't go one, two, three, four though.
It'll go zero, one, two, three.
So just know that arrays always start at zero.
And we'll get the percentage sign here, which is this.
We'll drag that into there and we'll just put that into there and then also get that.
So we're saying now we have the next camera in the array.
That's essentially what that's doing.
It's saying get the current camera, cycle to the next camera and say this is the camera that we want.
So now what we can do is we can get the player controller.
So get player controller.
So that's this here.
And then I want to drag off the player controller and say set view targets with blend.
So we'll set that.
We can change the blend time to one that I'll blend over one second.
If you want to change that blend to five or whatever you want to do, you can add that.
You can change the blend type easy and easy now.
And you can also change the exponent there, but I'm just going to leave all those settings for now.
Essentially, we just want to get the new view target.
So what we want to do is we want to get the list of cameras holding down control.
We want to drag off and get because we want to get a specific camera that's in the array.
And the camera that we want to get is this current camera.
So we can actually just drag that down there and then get that into there.
And that will essentially do all our heavy lifting for us.
So let's just save and compile and let's just see if that works right now.
So I'm going to add that.
We'll see that's a nice camera that we added first.
Let's see. Next camera.
Next camera.
And see now this is the downside of the system because now we're just blending.
So you want to make sure the cameras are far enough apart around there because we just went through the mesh.
But you'll see that it just keeps looping around, which is a really, really nice style camera system to have.
And it just gives us that nice little polish and functionality.
So we've got some cool angles and we can kind of just cycle through them.
That last one, a little bit clipping through the car.
So again, the order that we place them around the car will matter.
So maybe you want another one at the rear there on the left hand side of this frame just to make sure it circles around the car.
But that's essentially our UMG working.
And now we can dig into closing out the tutorial.